give you stage 5 minutes you could talk
about whatever you want
oh no well I would definitely if someone
came up to me and asked me what I felt
strongly about I would definitely say
pocket inequality I should want to talk
about the fact that it's not cool how
women's pants have such crappy pockets
with something that I've just been
really passionate about I'm wearing a
fanny pack if if you you know here here
you go I just went out and bought it and
it's honestly one of the best yeah fanny
pack it's one of the best investments
that I've made like lately like within
the past couple of years my pockets are
just I can't fit anything of substance
in here and it's nonsense cuz guys get
these big pockets and they can put their
phones and their wallets and change and
like probably like a burrito in there
and faux pockets what's the point of
faux pockets I'd rather just have a real
pocket you know what I mean
I don't know something I'm pretty
passionate about I think that's what's
what I have to say about it though yeah
that's that's my stand you
yes we are because often yes we do
[Music]
I'll talk about Disneyland because I'm
going there tomorrow so everyone always
says why do adults love Disneyland so
much and
can only say the only place we can be
kids
let your hair down
just wear Mickey ears and return like
you're five years old for eight hours
and scream on rides and it's just the
best feeling ever that's why I loved
I want to help me a restaurant I want to
go back to school but I've been lazy
lately maybe studying I'm only reading
what I used to I need to read I need to
work out that's not so mine it's tough
to be going in my head like I'm by
myself type stuff think about well
recently you know in my classes we
talked about organic foods in the
organic food industry and I absolutely
hate getting Cherie so that's a thing I
don't like how it like everyone has like
thing with GMOs and everyone's like
afraid of GMOs but they're really
excited not mad there's nothing wrong
with GMOs right
everyone thinks GMOs I leave this big
bad thing but if we didn't have GMOs
then we wouldn't have like bananas and
watermelon and stuff I don't think
people understand that GMO is just like
yield bigger bounties like we wouldn't
have as much corn as we did without GMOs
so the whole health craze thing I have
nothing against being healthy but a lot
of people are aren't very informed like
I even said I'm not super informed but I
do know some things not all things but I
have knowledge on some things well my
name is Fabi Paige I'm a dancer I does a
lot of dancing and I love to travel all
over the world I love to show my art and
I love to express myself physically
spiritually and mentally
that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]